hello everyone in case something seems a
bit odd I was invited to a costume party
and I didn't really have a costume so I
decided to do a mustache thing it kind
of seems like I'm doing a truck driver
but I'm actually going for something
more subtle still didn't decided what it
was and well I didn't really get to
celebrate our birthday yesterday so this
seems like a pretty good opportunity to
do it
that being Goddard the way we have a
very interesting game played by Aaron
names of which it was played in 1930 and
he's playing against Bjorn Nilsson
unfortunately I can find really any
information about the guy or a photo of
him
hence the hoodie guy again and unlike
the names of each game sure pretty used
to you know night of three going for
some hyper-modern ideas this game is a
pretty straightforward straightforward
destruction by our name Civic and he
plays the caro-kann well his opponent
plays the caro-kann but names which
plays the e4 move and it was played in a
simultaneous exhibition so this is even
more impressive and his opponent that
didn't really blend or anything or he
didn't play a bad more or anything like
that he just got outplayed by the great
names of it so let's see the game never
so he has the white pieces and nimza
which plays efore this is already
exciting we have c6 the caro-kann
defense d4 d5 Knight to c3 D captures on
e4 Knight captures the main line of the
caro-kann Knight to d7 the carpet
variation Knight to f3 Knight G to f6 we
had a night to g3e 6 Bishop to d3 all
pretty standard c5 nimzowitsch castles
Bishop to e7 c3 adding more protection
to d4 pawn Neilson castles rook to e1
and the b6 preparing to develop the
Bishop on b7 h3 Bishop to b7 and the
Bishop to b4 Bishop captures on f3 and
this is a this is a pretty hard decision
to do for black but as this is a
simultaneous exhibition we can probably
expect that his opponent wasn't really a
high rated player and as you know
players of lower ratings don't really
like the tension between pieces so they
they like to exchange Bishop captures an
f3 Queen captures on f3 and C captures
on d4 also the the tension in the center
really really bothers Nielson C captures
on d4 and Knight to d5 attacking that
Bishop on f4 we have Bishop the e4 now
and Knight to f6 as this bishop was
spinning the knight on d5 Nielson placed
Knight to f6 to now capture the light
square Bishop Bishop to e5 adding adding
up Bishop to e5 eyeing that g7 pawn if
the knight captures on e4 Knight
captures on e4 Queen captures on e4 and
now of course Knight to f6 and black is
feeling pretty confident here he's
playing against the great names of itch
and he he exchanged a lot of pieces he's
looking forward to Knight captures on e4
maybe playing Bishop to f6 exchanging
the bishop as well and nibsy which will
be left with this isolated d4 pawn and
black can really hope for hope for a
draw here but rook the c1 is played
Knight captures only for Queen captures
sorry rook captures on e4 and Queen to
d5 and it seems that the black really
managed to exchange pretty much all of
the pieces preparing Bishop to f6 or
something f6 is an idea definitely it's
it's hard to imagine that nimzowitsch
can go for something more than a draw
here the pin on on the rock on e4 isn't
really anything anything black can hope
for but here nimzowitsch starts a great
journey
he plays rook to c7 and okay this was a
simultaneous exhibition but if someone
played rook to c7 and if you were
playing a blitz game before playing
maybe a rapid game of 15 minutes or
something
pretty much the immediate response would
be Bishop to d6 and this is what news oh
it's opponent played the correct move
unfortunately in this position was
Bishop to d8 because Bishop to d6 allows
this nasty pin with rook to d7 but it
doesn't seem like rook to d7 is really
achieving anything here we have rook to
rook a to d8
now forcing the exchange of rooks and
it's really interesting what names are
which can do here and another option
here for black it seems like f6 is a
good move here but actually f6 loses
lose with a catastrophe if you play f6
you get rook to g4 and this is terrible
as you see of course rook captures and
g7 is a threat with a checkmate to
follow Bishop captures on f6 is an idea
if this is defended and if you play a
move like g6 unfortunately rook captures
on g6 wins by force this comes with
check if you accept the rook H captures
on g6 you get clean to d3 now
threatening Queen captures on g7 only
way to stop this is at five and after
Queen to g3 black has no more moves
Queen to G's Queen captures Angie says
with check and mate the follow is
unavoidable you can give up the rook but
this only prolongs the inevitable
so at rook to d7 names of each opponent
decided to play rook a to d8 completely
missing its main idea and this is this
is something something to enjoy for the
years to come as this was played in the
1930 so almost a hundred years for
people to enjoy this game names which
plays rook captures on these six what's
the idea here well obviously if you
don't want to resign you do have to
capture the rope so rook captures on d6
and here it comes
I will invite you since this is such a
great move especially from names of
which especially since he played efore
and especially since this is a
simultaneous exhibition where his
opponent really thought that him
managed to to exchange all the pieces
and we'll be able to draw a game against
the great names of it I invite you to
pause the video and and try to find
names of it just move I will give it a
couple of seconds as usual so there you
have it for those of you who managed to
find a name so it's move and okay it is
a bit easier when I say there is a move
but nevertheless I couldn't graduate you
this is quite a move to find and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show the move names of which played was
Queen to f6 and what's the idea here
well of course Bjorn Nielson resigned
the game here as he this was a
simultaneous exhibition I don't really
know the number of players that
participated in this event but it's
usually a 30 or 40 people event
so after names of each played Queen to
f6 he was probably taking a stroll you
know checking out the other games his
opponent did have time to think and in
the end he resigned the game what was
the plan here well if you ignore Queen
to f6 which is totally ridiculous for
example if you play b5 27 is checkmate
just in case you're not you're not
following what is happening if you
capture the Queen Queen capture she
captures Queen and f6
you get rook to g4 with check there is
no other moved and King to h8 and Bishop
captures opponent f6 this is checkmate
there is one more option after Queen to
f6
you can sacrifice the Queen with Queen
captures on e5 but after Queen captures
on e5 you're simply a Queen and the rook
against two rooks this is this is
ridiculous
so after Queen to f6 such a beautiful
such a beautiful move the Queen is the
queen is so close g7 and yet it cannot
be captured so his opponent resigned and
this beautiful game was achieved by our
names which in in a style that you're
not usually a usual used to see
by Aaron nimzowitsch so that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it and I don't
know why but today I actually got a lot
of the nation's I would like to thank
John Warner Don Dugan Armand and Arabic
even Luba touch and Nikolas cried too
for your double donation really
appreciated thank you a lot as usual you
can check to my previous videos here and
this will be the only video today as I
have something else planned like I said
I'm going to celebrate the rest of
Dallas birthday and I am preparing a
stream so all of you who are watching
this video are welcome to join my stream
the stream will start some probably 20
minutes after this video is uploaded and
the tournament will start probably some
40 minutes after this video is uploaded
so all of you are welcome to join I will
have a guest for this video it will not
be just me playing it will be my
neighbor some of you might have played
him in some of my previous tournaments
Yann almighty unleashes and I think it
will be it will be a great tournament
last tournament we had 320 players
participating so this time I will
announce it a bit sooner so maybe even
more players will enjoy the tournament
so yeah that's the game I do hope all of
you enjoyed it as I really enjoy a good
a good names of each game as as the guy
is amazing I mean he is somewhat of an
eccentric and I mean the guy was if you
ask a lot of people they will say news
which was crazy but he was quite a guy
so yeah that's it thank you for watching
and I will see you soon